beyoncé than sorry da liegst dafür dass
die beste freunde der sonne was hört ihr
eigentlich nur musik leute die indie und
rock hören sind intelligente als leute
die hip hop und an biel hören
das sagt diese grafik zusammengestellt
von dem programmierer virgil griffith
virtual verglich über 1300 amerikanische
colleges im hinblick auf zwei parameter
erstens welche musik ist an einem
bestimmten college besonders beliebt mit
hilfe von facebook fand er heraus
welches die zehn beliebtesten musiker
bands oder auch musikrichtungen an dem
jeweiligen college waren zweitens wie
schlau sind die studierenden an einem
bestimmten college einen hinweis darauf
gibt der durchschnittliche sls chor die
se tests sind standardisierte uni
zulassungstests die man abschließt muss
um an einem college angenommen zu werden
um in harvard angenommen zu werden
brauchen zum beispiel besonders hohe
scores und die durchschnittlichen ss
kurs kann man bei jedem college
öffentlich einsehen mit diesen daten
schaffte virtual das projekt music makes
you come in dem er die musiker bands und
genres dem durchschnittlichen escor
zuordnete und dabei ergaben sich
interessante zusammenhänge beethoven
fans mit abstand die schlausten auch
noch ganz schlaue fans von radiohead
oder youtube am dümmsten den fans auch
nicht viel schlauer beeinflusst unsere
intelligenz welche musik uns gefällt's
ich bin so intelligent ich vertrage
mozart und der ist natürlich oder ist es
andersrum hat mein musikgeschmack einen
einfluss auf meine intelligenz
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht mehr was zwei bier
zweites mal abgesehen davon dass schule
nicht das gleiche sind wie intelligenz
muss man hier sagen weder noch zwischen
musikgeschmack und schulen besteht hier
nur eine korrelation also nur ein
zusammenhang nicht unbedingt eine
kausalität also eine ursache korrelation
und kausalität sind nicht das gleiche
beispiel im sommer ziehen menschen
kürzere sachen an
dieser zusammenhang ist kausal wärmeres
wetter für zu luftigeren klamotten wenn
jetzt im sommer menschen aber gerne
kropp tops tragen dann ist das höchstens
ich sag mal halb causa wärmeres wetter
führt nicht automatisch zu dropbox
wärmeres wetter führte lediglich zu
kurzen klamotten und weil pop tops
gerade in mode sind und kurz gehen sie
mit warmen wetter einher aber sagen wir
jetzt mal die trendfarbe des sommers
2018 sei grün und alle laufenden grünen
klamotten rum dann wäre es natürlich
komplett falsch zu folgern dass warmes
wetter zu grünen klamotten führt wie
nahe jetzt korrelation und kausalität
zusammenhängen hat also immer was mit
dem kontext zu tun das alles weiß
virtual drive ist übrigens auch selbst
für ihn war das ganze eher ein witz denn
selbst wenn eine vorliebe für hiphop
einhergeht mit schlechteren noten heißt
das nicht automatisch dass hiphop
schlechte noten verursacht oder anderswo
korrelationen können aus reinem zufall
entstehen zum beispiel korreliert der
jährliche pro kopf käse konsum mit der
anzahl der todesfälle durch verheddern
im bett lagen womit man mehrere hundert
leute sterben sich verheddern im bett
lagen
ob die quelle muss man noch mal prüfen
heißt das jetzt käse verursacht
verheddern im bett lagen
unwahrscheinlich oder andersrum führen
solche todesfälle zu einem höheren käse
konsum wohl kaum
auch sehr schön die anzahl der filme mit
nicolas cage korreliert mit der anzahl
der todesfälle durch ertrinken in pools
korrelationen können reiner zufall sein
müssen das aber nicht gehen wir zurück
zum hiphop und den schlechten noten hier
ein paar unvollständige überlegungen
schlechte schulleistungen korrelieren
mit armut und einem schwächeren
sozioökonomischen status hip hop ist
eine musikrichtung deren kultur aus
einer
zur deckung heraus entstand und oft
gewalt oder kriminalität thematisiert
zwei dinge die ebenfalls korrelieren mit
einem schwächeren sozioökonomischen
status report fest die schulnoten können
also durchaus logisch verknüpft seien
allerdings in einem deutlich komplexeren
netz aus zusammenhängen ist also falsch
pauschal zu denken korrelationen sagen
nichts aus
korrelationen können nicht nur
aussagekräftig sein sondern sind in
manchen forschungsbereichen das beste
was man hat beispiel ernährungsforschung
bei labormäusen können ernährungs
studien systematisch durchgeführt werden
man kann kontrollieren was sie genau
messen wie viel sie sich genau bewegen
man kann sie tag und nacht überwachen
bei menschen geht das natürlich nichts
deshalb kann man auch nicht direkt
nachweisen was ein bestimmtes
nahrungsmittel oder eine bestimmte
ernährungsweise gesundheitlich genau
auslöst man kann nur zusammenhänge
feststellen also man kann zum beispiel
feststellen die gruppe die viele
karotten gegessen hat ist nach drei
monaten gesünder als die gruppe die
keine gurken gegessen hat das makler den
karotten liegen das mag auch an vielen
anderen dingen liegen und trotzdem wäre
es falsch zu sagen dass man mit
korrelationen keine ursachen erschließen
kann bei zucker und diabetes typ 2 zum
beispiel gibt es inzwischen so viele
verschiedene studien die sich
gegenseitig bestätigen und die
einhergehen mit allem was wir über den
zuckerstoffwechsel wissen und
herausgefunden haben so dass man mit
gutem gewissen sagen kann ein hoher
zuckerkonsum begünstigt diabetes typ 2
was ich jetzt damit sagen korrelation
ist nicht automatisch gleich kausalität
aber korrelation ist auch nicht
automatisch ungleich kausalität in ihre
wissenschaftliche zusammenhänge
vernünftig einordnen möchtet müsst ihr
zuerst herausfinden wie nahe korrelation
und kausalität beieinander liegen wenn
ihr in zukunft also über behauptungen
stolpert die kausalitäten beinhalten wie
zum beispiel vitamine machen schlauch
oder heiraten macht unglücklich dann
vermeidet voreilige schlüsse
besorgt euch genügend informationen und
vergesst nicht euren gesunden
verstand und nicht mehr gehen ich muss
euch noch was sagen freunde der sonne
miley hat zwei grimme online award
geworden einmal in der kategorie wissen
und bildung und den publikumspreis
ein publikumspreis für ein wissenschafts
format hat es möglicherweise auch noch
nicht gegeben seien
ich war fertig sprünge das andere ich
war fertig mit der welt
ich möchte mich also bedanken aber auch
dieser kanal ist den letzten monaten so
krass gewachsen so dass ich es alleine
nicht mehr schaffe alle kommentare zu
beantworten
aber ich lese sie noch aber bisher habe
ich immer zumindest versucht auf jedes
lob zu reagieren oder auf jede
glückwünsche und so weiter und nicht
persönlich zu bedanken einfach weil ich
es aber finde dass sich irgendjemand die
zeit nimmt um mir etwas nettes zu
schreiben was mich dann wiederum
motiviert
deswegen hiermit ein kollektives danke
an euch ihr wisst schon wer ihr seid wir
sehen uns nächsten donnerstag und bis
dahin platz sicher